on the 17th of june 1815
we marched through brussels amid the joy
of the inhabitants who brought us out
all manner of refreshments
i heard some remarks from them to the
effect that we were all going to be
slaughtered like
bullocks but we only laughed at this
telling them that that was nothing new
to us
some of the younger recruits however
were terribly downcast and frightened at
the idea of fighting
but i've often found that it is these
most timid ones
who when they come to an actual battle
rush forward
and get killed first probably owing to
the confused state they're in
while the more disciplined soldiers know
better or course to pursue
from brussels we march to about five or
six miles out of the town not far from
the village of waterloo when our
commander sent his aide to calm to lord
wellington for general orders how he was
to act
or as to what part of the line we were
to fall in at the orders returned were
that we were to stay in our present
position
till the next morning so that night we
crept into any hole we could find
cow sheds cart houses and all kinds of
farmstead buildings
for shelter and i never remember a worse
night in all the peninsula war
for the rain descended in torrance mixed
with fearful
thunder and lightning and seeming to
foretell the fate
of the following morning the 18th which
again
happened to be sunday
the allied army had on the 16th and 17th
been attacked by napoleon's large forces
at lignyi and cuatro brass during the
night of the 17th therefore
firing was continually going on which i
could distinctly hear
in spite of it being considerably
drowned by the thunder
all that night was one continued clamour
for thousands of camp followers were on
their retreat to brussels
fearful of sticking to the army after
the quattro brass affair
it was indeed a sight throwing to the
rain and continued traffic the roads
were almost impassable
and the people were sometimes completely
stuck in the mud
early in the morning of the 18th were
again put on the march to join our lines
and formed a line between merck bren and
monson gene on the brussels road
our regiment took to the left of this
road but did not remain there long
for the french were seen in motion and
on their opening fire from their cannon
we soon marched up to action in open
column
[Music]
during this movement a shell from the
enemy cut out deputy sergeant major in
two
and having passed on to take the head
off one of my company of grenadiers
named william hooper
exploded in the rear not more than one
yard from me
hurling me at least two yards in the air
but fortunately
doing me little injury beyond the
shaking and carrying a small piece of
skin off the side of my face
it was indeed another narrow escape for
it burned the tail of my sash completely
off
and turned the handle of my sword
perfectly black
i remember remarking to a sergeant who
was standing close by me when i fell
this is sharp work to begin with i hope
it'll end better
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
hello everybody hope you've been
enjoying the napoleonic content we've
been doing recently but a few more great
sources coming up to do with that
one of those is this we've got napoleon
in egypt so if this is something you're
interested in
leave a comment below so if this video
gives you a taste for the early 1800s
our recommendation this week is
trafalgar the greatest battle in naval
history
which is a fascinating dramatic
retelling of that fateful day
and that's magellan a great place to get
more context for our videos with more
than 3
000 documentaries available and the
collection is growing all the time
and you can now take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30
off an annual membership this gives you
an entire year for less than 3.50 a
month
even when you've joined magellan before
and lapsed
you can simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
at the commencement the commanding
officer was killed by a musket shot
but his place was soon filled up
and even this much had unfortunately so
frightened one of the young recruits of
my company
named bartram who had never before been
in action and now did not like the
curious evolutions of the shell so close
to him that he called out to me
and said he must fall out of rank as he
had taken very ill
i could easily see the cause of the
illness so i pushed him into rank again
saying
why bartram it's the smell of this
little powder that's caused your illness
there's nothing else the matter with you
but that physic would not content him at
all
and he fell down and would not proceed
another inch i was fearfully put out at
this
but was obliged to leave him for if he
had had his due
he would have been shot the right of our
line had been engaged some little time
before we were ordered up
and then our position was changed we
having to cross the road and proceed to
the right of a farmhouse
owing to the rain that had been
peppering down the whole night and it
even now not quite ceased
the fields and roads were in a fearful
state of dirt and mud
which tended to slow our progress
greatly as well as to tire us
about 10 o'clock the action of the day
began at hugomont on our right
and from there it fell on our center
where we were attacked by a tremendous
body of cavalry
and infantry the fire however which had
been kept up for hours from the enemy's
cannon
had now abated in that quarter owing to
the close unison of the two armies
and from this time onward we endured
some heavy work throughout the day
having constantly to be first forming
square
to receive the repeated attacks of their
cavalry and then line to meet their
infantry
charge after charge being made upon us
but with very little success
on the left on the turnpike road was
placed a brigade of german cavalry
with light horses and men when
bonaparte's bodyguards came up they
charged these
making fearful havoc amongst their
number still nothing daunted they formed
again and this time
ascended at us but of the two they met
with the worst reception than before
for we instantly threw ourselves into
three squares with our artillery in the
center
and the word having been given not to
fire at the men who wore
armor but at the horses which was obeyed
to the very letter
so as soon as they arrived at close
quarters we opened a deadly fire
and very few of them wholly escaped it
was the most laughable sight to see
these guards
in their chimney armor trying to run
away after their horses had been shot
from under them
i think this quite settled bonaparte's
bodyguards for we saw no more of them
they not having expected this signal
defeat
[Music]
that affair however had only passed off
a very few minutes before their infantry
advanced
and we had again to form the line ready
to meet them
we and our usual style at the infantry
get well within our musket shot
before the order was given to fire so
that our volley proved to be a fearful
success
we did not lose a single inch of ground
the whole day
though after these successive charges
our numbers were fearfully thinned
and even during the short interval
between each charge the enemy's cannon
had been doing some mischief among our
ranks besides
the men in their tired state were
beginning to despair but the officers
cheered them on continually through the
day with the cry of keep your ground my
men
it is a mystery to me how it was
accomplished for at last
so few were left that there was scarcely
enough to form square
about four o'clock i was ordered to the
colours
this although i was used to warfare as
much as any was a job i did not at all
like
they had been before me that day 14
sergeants already killed
and wounded while in charge of those
colours with officers in proportion
and the staff and colours were almost
cut to pieces
this job will never be blotted from my
memory
i remember it as if it had been
yesterday i had not been there more than
a quarter
of an hour when a cannon shot came and
took the captain's head
clean off this was again close to me for
my left side was touching the poor
captain's right
and i was spattered all over with his
blood one of his company who was close
by to me at the time
cried out hello there goes my best
friend which caused the lieutenant to
quickly step forward to take his place
to say to the man never mind i will be
as good a friend to you
as the captain i hope not sir the man
replied
the officer not having rightly
understood his meaning the late captain
having been particularly hard on him for
his dirtiness
giving him extra duty and such like as
punishment this man whose name was
martin
was a notorious character in the
regiment on account of his dirtiness
he'd been transferred to this fifth
company when either the poor captain had
been able to reform him
try however he might still he was for
all this
an excellent soldier in the field
but now i must get on to the very last
charge of cavalry
which took place not long after this few
as we were
when we saw it coming we formed squares
and awaited it then we poured volley
after volley into them
doing fearful execution and they had to
retire at last before the strong dose we
administered
not however without our losing more men
and so becoming even weaker than before
that we were dreading another charge
but all the help we got was the cry of
keep your ground my men
reinforcements are coming not a bit
however did they come
till the setting sun in time to pursue
our retreating enemy
the prussians having been detained
elsewhere i must say here that i cannot
think why those charges of cavalry were
kept up against our unbroken squares
in spite of their being so constantly
sent back it is murder to send cavalry
against disciplined infantry unless they
have artillery to act in conjunction
with them
[Music]
we were indeed glad to see the arrival
of these prussians who are now coming up
in two columns on our left flank
advancing on the enemy's right lord
wellington who was ever enticing his
army on
now came up to our regiment and asked
who was in command on being told it was
captain brown
he gave the order to advance which we
received with three cheers
and set off as if renewed with fresh
figure the attack was now being made by
the whole
line together with the prussians who had
come up fresh and were therefore more
than a match for the harassed french
they soon forced the french into a
downright retreat by their fire
and the retreat becoming universal the
whole body of the french were thrown
into disorder
and pursued off the field we followed
them ourselves for about a mile and then
encamped on the enemy's ground
and if there was a hungry and tired
tribe of men we were just that
after that memorable day of the 18th of
june
then the first thing to be thought of
was to get a fire and cook some food
which was not so easy as wood was scarce
and what there was was wet through
one of our company named rouse who went
in search of sticks came across one of
the enemy's powder wagons that we had
taken in the battle amongst the rest of
many things
and immediately commenced cutting the
cover up for fuel
but his hook coming in contact with a
nail or some other piece of iron and
striking fire
as a natural consequence the remains of
the powder in the wagon exploded and
lift the poor fellow up
to a considerable height in the air the
most remarkable thing
was that he was still alive when he came
down unable to speak
though everything had been blown from
him except one of his shoes
he was a perfect black guard for
although he was in a most dangerous
state
he did not refrain from cursing his eyes
which happened
as it was to be both gone he was that
night conveyed to brussels hospital
with the rest of the many wounded and
died in a few days
raving mad
[Music]
we succeeded however in getting a fire
at last
we sat down and made a very good meal
off our ham and poultry
and i can safely say we enjoyed our mess
as much as any man ever did
i for one had had nothing to eat since
early in the morning up until that time
after that as the general did not want
us for anything we retired to rest on
our straw
but i was too tired to go to sleep for a
long time and lay
contemplating the scenes of the day of
the general blood loss on that
blood-stained day
i'm unable to give an exact account but
it must have been enormous on both sides
for 300 of my regiment alone were
missing and this was not so great a loss
as some other regiments
chiefly from the continual fire of shot
and shell that the french cannon had
kept up between the charges
i was merely scratched on the face
myself during the whole day
besides being a little shaken by the
bursting of the shell i mentioned
but this scratch had been terribly
aggravated by a private who'd been
standing next to me having overprimed
his musket
with the consequence that when he fired
my face being so close
the powder flew up and caught my wound
which though only originally a slight
one
soon made me dance for a time without a
fiddle
there was very little delay and early
next morning we were again put in motion
to prevent our enemy if possible from
getting any breathing time